it's an audit meeting 25th of november
the meeting today of governance and
audit
the meeting today of the governance and
audit
both those that are participating and
those who are watching from home
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting
then please contact democratic services
officer who will
attempt to assist you today's officer on
call is katie and the number to call
is 577046
i would ask participants when you're not
speaking
please mute your microphone this
minimizes background noise
and will help everybody to listen to the
proceedings
microphones must only be
on if the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate
on the chat box on the right hand side
of the screen i will then make a note
and go back to you
once the person speaking has finished
the meeting environment would everybody
present
please ensure their mobile phones are
turned silent
and they're not used to make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from discrete distractions
for the duration of the meeting
meeting recording please note this
meeting is being live streamed
for members of the public the meeting
will also be recorded
and will be subsequently broadcast on
the internet
attendance please can i ask members of
the committee
to confirm their present in the meeting
when i read out your name
i will ask for the attendance of those
counselors
who are participating in order to speak
under
council rule 2021 separately
councillor dexter president chairman
councillor boyd president chairman
councillor braidwood
[Music]
councillor christendon
councillor curry here chair
councillor ghana i'm here chair
councillor coop here chair
councillor pat moore
councillor shrub here chao
councillor towning
and i have apologies do i have any
apologies for
absence i have received apologies for
counselor k
campbell already uh yes chair apologies
from councillor crittenden
are there any members who would like to
speak under 2021
20.1 i haven't really received any
requests
are there any declaration of interests
at this meeting
now to approve the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of september
2020
copy attached to the agenda pack please
can i have a proposer and a seconder
i'll propose councillor ghana second
councillor cup
i'll take those minutes as approved then
thank you
we now move on to item 4 on the agenda
i'd like to ask simon webb to introduce
the report please
thank you chair good evening members
this is the regular quarterly internal
audit
update report which provides members
with an update of the work completed by
the east cambodia partnership on your
behalf
since the last meeting of this committee
it also contains details of the
performance of the east kentucky
partnership to the 30th of september
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 11
that summarizes the five new audit
assignments completed during this period
we were pleased to report substantial
assurance in the areas of hmo and
selective licensing
and also the management and monitoring
of expenditure
expenditure associated with phones
mobiles and utilities
we concluded limited assurance in two
areas
they were grounds maintenance and also
the disclosure and bar
in service checks which are undertaken
on your behalf
by the east chem hr partnership
we also undertook an unplanned
assignment which was an investigation
into an
incorrect payment we are pleased to
report that this was
solely due to human error and not due to
any systemic control weakness within the
control regime
and recommendations have been made to
ensure that it doesn't happen again
follow-up is an inter a very important
part of internal audit work
um about three to six months after the
original audit assignment
we go back to ensure that the agreed
action plan
recommendations have been implemented
drawing your attention
to the table on page 17 you'll see that
there were two follow-ups undertaken in
the last quarter
one and perhaps the most important one
was a follow-up of east kent housing
tenant health and safety
the specific area covered was fire
safety
there has been improvement in this area
and the insurance level has increased
from no assurance to limited
it will however take some time for the
implemented controls to become embedded
and for the fire actions to be
implemented across the district for that
reason
it's too early to increase the insurance
level to reasonable
but the direction of travel is
undoubtedly positive
the other follow-up which we undertook
was east kent housing benefits appeals
that was substantial at the time of the
original audit and
um his report was substantial and after
follow-up
drawing your attention to the table on
page 21
and the following pages that details
progress against the agreed
2021 internal plan showing time spent
against each of the audit assignments
and where we are with each of the audits
there's also a table for east kent
housing
as members will be aware their housing
service was brought back in-house on the
30th of september
and also these ken services east kent hr
and civica
i would then like to draw your attention
to um
page 29 and page 30 of the report that
shows the balanced score card
of um keep performance indicators for
the east ken halley partnership
and it shows our performance to the 30th
of september
in terms of probably the most important
and one of those kpis
which is planned progress at
30th september we had completed just
under 43
of your plan against the half year
target 50
so we're running a little bit um behind
schedule um
but considering that we lost the best
part of three months to go with 19
at the start of the year um we are
progressing very well with the plan
now and i'm reasonably confident that um
we will have a very very respectable
performance
um to report by the time we reach the
31st of march
in terms of plan completion
that's it members in terms of my
presentation but obviously happy to take
questions on any of the audio
assignments
contained within the report thank you
very much
i would yeah thank you yeah thank you
simon for that report
um i've just got a couple of
concerns really about this section on
grounds maintenance
um you mentioned in the report
that um while the serv
service has defined service standards
which is great
there are no kpis in place to help
detect
and measure successful outcomes so
to my mind that sounds like um
you know it doesn't really matter how
good the the um
service standards are if they're not
being measured
then we're not knowing we don't know if
anything is being done
um correctly or to the right standard so
that's
a bit of a concern so to start to ask
how
how long that's been the case that there
hasn't been any
um kpis in place to measure standards
and that's particularly a concern to me
because
um at the end of last year the park and
open spaces standards were updated
quite significantly following um
some quite a big public outcry around
hedge cutting at the winter
gardens and we were assured that these
new standards was going to prevent
similar
things happening again but if service
standards aren't being
measured then how can we know that um
that things have changed so that that's
one point
i'd like to make and with one question
to ask
also you mentioned one of the other
points is the interim nature of the
management arrangements
which has been for over a year um
so obviously this doesn't help and maybe
that has got a bit of a
bit of a impact on the first point i was
just making
why there aren't any kpis in place i
mean
if you had any assurance as to when this
is going to
change and when there are going to be
more permanent
management arrangements in place thank
you
thank you councillor thank you chair um
at the time of the last review
um there weren't um service standards in
place
and so at that time we made a number of
critical um
recommendations in that regard we are
pleased to report that service standards
have now been
adopted um and you mentioned um
that you oversaw the adoption of those
um said service standards
you're quite right in saying that they
do need to be accompanied by
key performance indicators to measure
performance against those
um i mentioned that follow-up is an
important part of internal audit work
and we will be going back within the
next three months
to ascertain whether those kpis have now
been
implemented and if they are
being reported to members on a regular
basis
i think undoubtedly the interim nature
of some of the management arrangements
have contributed
to a delay in establishing kpis
i think once there is a permanent
management structure in that area um it
will
um help facilitate um both the
establishment of
those kpis and their monitoring to drive
continuous improvement in the grounds
maintenance service
so as i say we will be undertaking the
follow-up in within the next three
months
and reporting back i would like to be
bringing the follow-up on this to the
next meeting of this committee
which if memory serves me correctly i
think it's the third of march
does that answer your question
councillor gardner
um it does yeah
i mean have you been given any assurance
that the
um these are going to be followed up so
that you can report
in the next meeting that these kpis
been kpi's we have
um received agreement to the um those
recommendations
um within the action plan so yes
management have agreed to the adoption
of them
um and we will be monitoring the
implementation of them
and as i say yes i will look to report
back to the
meeting on the third of march okay
thank you very much thank you
i have a question from council roy
dexter
uh thank you mr chairman um i'd like uh
to ask a question um of from simon
simon webb if you look at page 11
and the chart there is under 2.2 which
is phones mobiles and utilities
um you have an assurance level there of
substantial
but then when you go to the chart on
page 30 13
under telephones you have a value there
for 1920
of 240 000 pounds
and that's a whopping increase
from 18 to 19.
over to you
thank you councillor the assure
assurance opinion
is based upon the strength of the
internal controls
that are present within the system as
opposed to the level of expenditure
i could certainly find out for you why
the level of expenditure on telephones
had increased
as you say from 1819 to 1920
but the level of expenditure in itself
wouldn't affect the assurance statement
sure statement is based upon the
robustness of the system of internal
control
um probably about
looking at that about 40 in one year
and get back to councillor dexter on
that subsequently
all right thank you thank you
right we have uh
no more questions showing on that
item uh is the recommendation
that the report be received by members
has everybody agreed
yeah we now
move on to audit findings report which
has been um
we have we have to have a discussion
with um
chris and sarah about this as there's an
issue with the
valuation of one of the properties
should i ask
uh chris can you go to this one first
absolutely thank you chair
yes unfortunately due to some
information that's only
um come to the auditor's attention right
at the end of the
audit there's a material difference on
the valuation
of one of our assets um in terms of the
uh
that stated in the balance sheet at the
moment um
where are in discussions with grant
thornton as to
the position that that asset should be
presented
in the accounts um however we've not
been able to reach an agreement then
because
of the size of the difference in
the valuation of the assets and and the
opinion of it
um it's uh it will not be possible for
the audit to be concluded
prior to the deadline on the 30th
of november so it's regrettable
um that we've got to the situation as i
said it's an uh
a piece of information that's only come
to light at the end of the order it is
uh in relation to the valuation of one
particular asset
and as we will be
recommending to you chair and to the
committee that
the audit finance reports alongside
the associated papers for the assurance
statement and the statements that
accounts
are deferred into the next meeting
thank you um sarah manga would you like
to
make comments on this issue as well um
yes so i think in our audit findings
report that is on the
agenda there are a number of items when
we wrote that that were outstanding
and one of those has come back to a
position where we have more information
where it is a really technical part of
evaluation
um it is not something either the
finance team or the audit team
um wanted to be in um because
because the rest of the audit has drawn
to a close
it is frustrating for all of us that
we're not able to resolve this one issue
to be able to um to be able to say that
we should be presenting our audit
findings report
because of the technical nature of it we
just feel that it is
it is better to reach a resolution to
that
and come back to you uh member to your
committee and to members to present
what that final position is and how that
has
impacted um the financial statements
and that's our position on it as it is
today
thank you that leaves us with pulling
items five six and seven
from the agenda to be dealt with um at
the later
date when the committee resits and the
valuations have been agreed
it was it's been decided because uh it's
too large an item just to leave for
officers
um to under delegated powers
uh so the whole committee will have to
sit again either
um in march or in an emergency meeting
before then
we'll now move on to
mid-year review 2021 treasury management
and annual investment strategy
i'd ask mr blundell to report please
thank you chair so this is the first of
two reports that are on the agenda in
relation to treasury management so this
first one
is a mid-year review of the position of
the
of the current financial year of 2021.
i'm pleased to report that there are no
exceptional items
in terms of us operating outside our
agreed treasury management
framework um with the the
one item that i do want to bring to the
committee's attention is a proposal
um and i should say that this was agreed
at cabinet but is
referred to council for final approval
so that section three is for us to amend
our
um treasury management strategy to allow
a lower
grading of investment for particular
types of investments
now this is because of changes to the
economic environment and we're looking
at a number of
high street banks that had a marginal
decrease in their credit rating
so at the moment we use a grade as the
minimum for level 3 for our specified
investments and we're looking going to a
minus um
that's that's not a it's only one
grade down and it still incorporates
what we considered investment grade
and this will obviously allow us to
undertake our treasury management
activities
in a more effective and efficient manner
manner by
uh maintaining the pool and number of uh
counterparties that we can
um invest with i'm happy to take any
further questions or
um welcome comment from the committee on
the report
does anybody have any questions about
that report
nothing in the chat box at the moment
right
okay uh
can i have a proposer and a seconder
please
unless you're injured injury that's
approved then
well mr chairman i'll recommend for
approval
i'll second it
we might have lost the chairman
yeah i think we have yeah oh there we go
we're back i just got asked to um
rate the meeting how i thought of it
can i can i just say mr chairman that um
i did recommend the report for approval
and i think you'll find that councillor
shrub
has second the motion good
thank you so that's that's approved
right
we move on to the quarterly risk
management report
there's a question in the chat box and
council of ghana that you may wish to
address before moving on to the next
item
right yeah please sorry if you don't
if you don't want sorry we sort of moved
on from um
the audit findings report quite quickly
and i didn't quite get a
chance to ask i'm i'm a little bit lost
while we
i understand why we can't finalize the
report because of the item
talked about by by mr blundell but
i don't understand why the other items
covered there like the assurance
statement
um can't be discussed um
can you just clarify that for me again
um chair would you like me to oh yes
please exist
um so counselor we we have discussed
this and i think we thought because
in approving your accounts you have to
consider what we
say in the audit findings report and the
assurance statement is something that we
consider as part of our defining report
we thought as a package they should come
together
um as one because they're all
interlinked with each other
okay all right okay i'll get that but i
thought
thought i read somewhere in here that we
have to sign all this off
by the 30th of november that we were
going to delegate powers
potentially or call an extraordinary
meeting
but now it sounds like we're just
for my information we're talking about
kennedy it's going to wait till next
march now
there is further discussions needed
between the finance and audit team
to reach an agreement on what amendments
um and in fairness to the finance team
if any um are required we consider there
are
significant amendments needed um we need
to work
through that process to reach a view
it's hard for you to
um approve the set of accounts when we
consider there to be material amendments
as i said they're of a technical nature
and and the resolution
will it will be easier for you to
challenge
if we've been able to set out that
technical nature
uh in writing for you to consider in
advance
um and that's and that's really the
position that we're in
okay so but you are saying that the the
whole thing about
having to do it by the end of november
isn't actually something that
we do have to do um legally
that that is the date that is set um
so it will mean that you will not meet
that
date um you will not be the only
authority
where um that date is not met
okay yeah maybe i could just um assist
council ghana
um yes ideally we would
publish our accounts by the 30th and
have them signed off which is why we
have this meeting on the 25th of
november
um and it is unfortunate that we are in
this position
the only way to save the position would
have been for the committee to have
agreed
the accounts and then delegated to me
to agree the details with
sarah and grant thornton so that that
could be resolved before the 30th of
november
but having discussed it with the
external auditors i have concluded that
i wouldn't recommend that
to this committee because i think the
issue at hand is what's called material
so it's over a certain value
so that there's a question there about
um
it would be more appropriate for the
committee to have that in front of them
when it's agreeing the final accounts
not delegate that to
to me with grant thornton um and
uh it's also quite technical and it
would be challenging in any case to
resolve it
over the next few working days so we've
concluded that unfortunately we're not
going to be able to have
a set of accounts by the end of november
that isn't in keeping with the date that
has been set which is the 30th of
november but but it's just being
realistic and it's managing the risks
but it's probably safer just to accept
that
the whole issue of the accounts together
with as sarah says
the um the assurance letter and the
audit findings report
are all put back until a future date
which
at the moment the next committee meeting
is in march but there could be a special
committee meeting earlier than that if
if the chair and members wanted to do
that
okay thank you very much sir that helps
yeah thanks
that's clear um the the next agenda item
um we're with mr blundell okay
yep uh thank you chair uh so item nine
treasury management strategy
statement minimum revenue provision
policy statement and annual investment
strategy for 2122.
so um nice snappy short title there
this is the second treasury management
report on the agenda and this is the
forward look
so this is actually our our strategy for
the fourth coming year
uh setting out our our broadly our
treasury management
strategy and policies which is largely
unchanged
from the current year and also our
capital expenditure plan so
we've obviously not finalized the budget
yet
and this report will be or a form of it
will be
presented to council for approval at the
same time as the budget
as if there are any changes to our
capital expenditure plans they will be
reflected in this strategy uh
that said looking through the report you
see within
the executive summary there's a capital
expanded forecast
of 37 35.7 million pounds over the next
three years and borrowing acquired and a
region of 4.8 million pound
um it's also worth noting there's no
change to the minimum
revenue provision policy and that's the
policy that we have in place to
effectively make sure we're putting
enough money aside
to pay off our debt every year
in addition to that the report also sets
out the amendments that were reflected
in
the previous report that i looked at
into that we looked at in terms of the
downgrading of the credit rating so that
would also be
in effect for the next financial year
um so as i said this report is
effectively presented to the committee
for
comments and further recommendation on
for
formal approval at council in february
happy to take any questions
we we have no uh comments in the uh
comment box
on this at the moment uh so i think
we'll move
move on to uh proposer and the seconder
unless i hear otherwise uh i'll take
this item as approved
and move on to authority could someone
propose that for us and
get a second app from there
from the committee i'll propose that
chair
i'll second that mr chair
that's approved
a gender item 10 quarterly risk
management report
i'll call on mr blundell to introduce
the report please
thank you chair yes this is a that's me
again hopefully this report is
a little bit more uh in think perhaps
than the previous two treasury
management items and
of uh more committing so
this is the regular quarterly update
that the committee receives in relation
to
corporate risks um looking at section
four sets out the corporate risk
register so these are the main risks
that we consider from a corporate
perspective
um and there's within the table below
section 4.2
setting out the scores at september and
revised scores for the committees review
in november so you'll see there's been
one risk that's been added and that's in
relation to
uh the risk of a cyber attack that was
previously
on just on our service risk register so
it is a risk that we've been
aware of throughout the organization but
due to events that have happened across
local government where other authorities
have been subject to
cyber attacks this has now been
escalated to a corporate risk because
we um are aware of the potential impact
uh and on the committee you have
oversight of that
in addition you'll see the other change
the report is a downgrading of the risk
reduced risk from 16 in
september to nine in november relating
to east kent housing
performance but more probably more um at
this
point in time the transition so that
reflects that those risks have reduced
due to an initial successful transition
of the service to an in-house
service i'm happy to take any questions
on the report
counselor mike garner would like to ask
a question go ahead please
thank you yes at the um at the last
governance
an audit meeting i asked a question on
this report
about the political stewardship
piece um uh
as how that's made up and why it's so
high
and i think because um mr house wasn't
at the meeting
um so i was advised to get in contact
with him about
it um because and he
he's told me that that all it is the
only reason
that that is high is because we have a
council with no overall control
and there isn't any other reason it's
and i'm a bit confused about
that because i think it was suggested
that there may have been a number of
factors
involved in this at the last week you
know i just want to fully understand
why us being a council of no no
overall control would have a such a high
um political stewardship risk
especially well that's what i'd like to
ask
please
chad i think it's probably best if i
defer that to um
mr house as the risk owner for this
particular risk
actually i'm not the risk
chairman it's actually i'm the owner of
of that risk
um i think um i i entirely appreciate
council for ghana the
the point that you're making um
because it sounds very serious doesn't
it and
actually as a as a council we are
functioning perfectly well uh
but i think the reason it's in it's in
there as a corporate risk and it's in
there
at that level because we are in uh no
overall control that means that at any
point there could potentially be a
change to the administration of the
council
uh and as a result of that that that
potentially
may doesn't have to but may create
some uh destabilization or change in
direction around how the council
functions so
i think it's around just recognizing
that we're not necessarily
in a um permanent
position in a way that we would be if we
had an administration that had overall
control
and and therefore the certainty of that
and i think that's what that's trying to
reflect
okay so i guess that means any any
council
in the uk with uh
that isn't uh like ours no overall
control they'd all have a
high as high risk as that
i suspect that would be i'll be
surprised not to see it listed as a
corporate risk in the council in a
similar position yes is the answer to
that yeah
answered a good question thank you very
much
i'd ask members
to note this report
and that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting
i declare this meeting closed at uh
5 40. thank everybody for
participating and those watching from
home
on the live stream the meeting will now
end thank you all very much
good night